depuis le mois de mai jour après jour
les éducatrices dans les services de
garde portent un masque qui ne les
protège pas le modèle mc 95,01 présente
des lacunes importantes au niveau de la
filtration
tellement que la cnss télé jugent non
conforme
certaines particules du virus peuvent
passer au travers
bacon le sus on a agi parce que
évidemment la santé place du personnel
ben non c'est bien mais bien plus value
séparant gaza
le ministère de la famille a envoyé
cette communication mardi soir au réseau
pour lui demander de cesser
immédiatement d'utiliser ces masques un
total de 31 millions de mc 95,01 auront
été porté par les éducatrices durant la
pandémie 31 millions de fois où elles
auraient pu être infectés par le virus
s'inquiète leur association
même si moins de 1000 cas ont été
recensés au total il ya des doutes ce
qui ne marche pas encore il faut les
porter dans l'ombre
on a des enfants qui ont besoin d'être
rassurés consoler donc c'est ce qu'on
doit s'assurer d'avoir des équipements
de protection individuelle qui sont de
bonne qualité dans ce que tu as fait
inacceptable et un sens là je pense que
ça démontre une certaine désorganisation
les partis d'opposition à québec
demandent au gouvernement de rendre des
comptes au sujet des achats massifs
qu'ils effectuent pour équiper les
employés du réseau public et avoir la
plus grande transparence
qu'est ce qui s'est passé et pourquoi
les éducatrices n'ont pas eu droit à la
même protection que beaucoup de
travailleurs au public le lot de masques
problématique est pratiquement écoulé
déjà les services de garde avait
commencé à recevoir des nouveaux qui
répondent aux exigences de sécurité mais
pas tous en attendant que leurs bureaux
coordonnateurs plus leur en fournir en
janvier certains doivent eux mêmes les
acheter dans les commerces ils si
véronique prince radio canada québec